[Music]
this
is star talks sports edition i'm your
host
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and this week we decided to visit our
archives
just from a few years ago back to a
discussion
that has become prevalent in the sports
sphere over the past few years
and that's gender in sports my co-host
chuck nice and gary o'reilly they
originally recorded this episode
back in 2018 when caster cement
an intersex woman with naturally high
testosterone levels
was scrutinized for her winning
performance as a runner
so since then this conversation has
continued to garner public attention
various laws are being proposed to limit
transgender and intersex athletes
in how they can participate in sports
and
and that the fact that laws are being
discussed means this
is a topic of consideration
and as for the tokyo olympics athletes
such as the new zealand weightlifter and
transgender woman
laurel hubbard is sparking important
conversations and we thought it'd be
valuable to bring back
this archival episode so we hope you
enjoy this examination of the science of
gender
and how our expanding knowledge of human
physiology
might help us think more objectively
about our society
and what we deem to be fair in modern
sports
check it out i think we have a
particularly
interesting guest joining us now dr
joanna harper
is a transgender and gender veteran
athlete
an endurance runner a medical physicist
at providence portland medical center in
oregon
and the only person in history chuck to
publish a peer-reviewed article on the
performance of transgender
athletes welcome to the show um okay
joanna
let's start with a few of the
vocabulary and terminology so as i
understand so
if we go through exactly what
transgender
intersex biological and anatomical sex
and how this all unfolds if you could
base that for my platform to work from
please
both sex the biology of the male
female divide and gender the sociology
of the male female divide
are complex and we can divide
biological sex into different categories
like
external genitalia internal genitalia
chromosome pattern
hormones secondary sex characteristics
and these are not all necessarily
concordant
so you know some people might possibly
have
external genitalia of one
sex and and internal genitalia uh
assorted with the
the opposite sex gender is
is also complex um many people nowadays
talk about
gender fluidity that implies a
one-dimensional
continuum between male and female but i
actually like to think of gender as a
two-dimensional
graph in which we have male female along
a vertical axis
and then the number of gender aspects
along
the horizontal aspect and
in particular with sports i i like to
think of
gender assigned at birth social gender
legal gender and a concept that i like
to call
athletic gender others have used terms
like sports sex
but but we're talking about the same
thing gender for the purpose of sport
and so so these things are complex but
i think we can narrow this down in terms
of sports
you did warn us it was complex um you
you have advised the ioc the
international olympic committee
on guidelines regarding sex reassignment
and
hyper androgenism um the athlete that
springs to mind
is simmenia but i think we're going to
get a little bit more in depth with that
later on
when we talk but all right our athletes
here we go simple question are athletes
being gender tested at the olympics
right now
uh in the 2016 and 2018 olympics
there was no testing anyone who had been
assigned female at birth was allowed to
compete in 2016 and 2018.
whether there will be some sort of test
for 2020 remains to be decided
okay is there a blanket ruling as the
ioc
the iwaf the international athletics
association if i remember it federation
and the ncaa
all of these large governing bodies do
they have
the same rules or are they all varied
they all vary um the
certainly the iwaf and the ioc
coordinate but but they haven't always
had the same rules
um and the ncaa is a completely
different
uh organization with its different set
of rules but
in the last seven or eight years all
three of these organizations
have have come to center around the idea
that hormones are the most important
aspect
for determining who gets to compete in
in the male or female categories
so they're looking at hormones and what
are they proposing
or is there any kind of universal uh
proposition being put forward
to create a standard and should there be
well i um i guess first question first
um the ncaa since uh 2011
has used a testosterone-based standard
for transgender athletes um intersex
athletes are not a big concern
uh in the ncaa uh because
the prevalence in north america is is
less and and there are other
complicating factors but
but mostly the ncaa just has to concern
themselves with transgender the iwaf
and the ioc both have to consider
intersex and transgender
and they have separate policies for each
of these
as i say the ilc has not had a policy on
intersex athletes
since the 2014 olympic games the ioc
has a transgender policy
that has been in place since 2011
they have a new dsd
regulations that govern intersex
athletes
that will start to take uh
place in november 1st of 2018 so just a
few weeks from now
um so the second thing should they all
be the same well
not necessarily i think i i think we
should look at elite athletes
differently than we look at low-level
athletes
but but i think the ncaa is high enough
uh a level of sport that they should
probably be fairly close
okay and can you do me a favor because
as you were talking about intersex
athletes
i'm sure that there's a goodly portion
of the listening audience that's not
familiar with that
and um in doing so maybe visit the fact
that this
everybody thinks that this is a very new
and
uh even though it's very nuanced it
really isn't a new thing i mean this
has a very long history going back to
the olympics in like what the 30s
right yes and and certainly intersex
people before then
you know in the 19th century you had
bearded ladies you you had
these sorts of things um so intersex
people
who have either physical and or
chromosomal characteristics that in some
manner
blur the uh line between male and female
until the 21st century these people were
generally called
hermaphrodites so
so many people might be more familiar
with that
and intersex people their conditions are
called dsds or
differences of sexual development uh so
i use the term intersex and dsd uh
interchangeably uh but um but many
people might be more familiar with
hermaphrodite
and so when when we're talking about
let's
kind of transition because uh to
transgender
and you wrote an article uh let me get
the
the title right cause i read it and it
was in the washington post and they said
do transgender athletes
have an edge and then you said in the
title i sure don't
now i read that article and i have to
say that
the the uh title is somewhat misleading
because people i'm sure will kind of
maybe
cruise through it or read in a cursory
fashion or
just read the headline and think that
you feel
there is no advantage whatsoever for
being transgender
and competing but i read the article
that's not what you're saying at all
you're not saying that so please
for those people who might not
understand what you're really saying
can you clear it up for them absolutely
first of all
organizations like the washington post
have people who write titles
for them yes yes and you i'm sure you
know that
so i wrote the article somebody else
wrote the headline
and anybody who reads the article this
is why i'm bringing this up
if you read the article you realize that
somebody slapped a headline on there
to make you read the article but the
headline and the article
are really not in sync so can you just
tell us when it comes to advantages
what you really feel i don't want to put
words in your mouth i read the article
but i want to put words in your mouth
and just let people know what you're
really saying
okay so most people are concerned about
transgender
women people who start life as
biologically male and then transition to
female
competing in women's sports and many
people say that trans women have
advantages
over normal women or cisgender women
and and that's actually true um even
after hormone therapy which makes
enormous differences
but even after hormone therapy
transgender women are on
average taller bigger and stronger than
cisgender women
and in many sports those are
advantageous
however transgender women also have a
large
frame that they're now trying to power
with reduced muscle mass and reduced
aerobic capacity
so so that's a disadvantage so trans
women
have advantages but disadvantages too
and then the most important question is
can transgender women and cisgender
women
compete against one another in an
equitable and meaningful fashion
if they can they belong in the same
category if they can't
they don't belong in the same category
it's interesting
when we look at your personal journey
because you're an endurance runner
and it's all about i don't need the
weight i don't need this
extra thing to drag this long distance
are you saying that
when you went through your process
that it became particularly
disadvantaged
to you and if so can you explain the
processes that you went through and the
disadvantages that came with it
muscle mass still helps transgender
athletes and
as a trans woman i carry more muscle
mass than cisgender women and
and so that helps but but certainly the
fact that
um you know i mean i'm not a huge person
but
by female distance runner standards i'm
i'm you know
bigger bigger than average and so you
know that is a disadvantage
and so what i found in my particular
case
is that after nine months of hormone
therapy i was running
12 percent slower and that's the
difference between
male distance runners and female
distance runners so i had lost that
advantage
uh over 12 months or over nine months
rather
and and then i started finding other
transgender distance runners and the
same thing had happened to them
and and that made the basis of my study
but but in particular if you want to
look
really closely at it when i was running
in men's competition
my best event was the marathon so the
longer the race the better i did
but that's actually no longer true my
best race distances
as a woman are 5k to 10k and and that be
speaks of of my
advantage of a little more muscle mass
but my disadvantage of having a little
more
uh frame and so um
i'm still pretty good at longer
distances but i'm now
best at 5k so there's been a little
shift
it's interesting so now you you you talk
and discuss this
is there a sort of specific events
that would benefit some that don't some
that do the advantage disadvantage
scenario within sports and different
sports
absolutely one one would expect um
basketball volleyball weightlifting
those sorts of sports you might think
would be sports for transgender women
would have advantages
in gymnastics transgender women are
going to be
hugely disadvantaged so disadvantaged in
fact that
i predict that i will never live to see
an elite
trans woman gymnast never wow
so now when you talk about and i would
say maybe you can speak to this or not
and maybe you've come across this in
your studies or not
but i will say that when it comes to
games then that
require both uh hand-eye coordination
skill sets and strength that
you really have i mean you really can't
say that there's an
advantage to being a transgender or not
because
you still have to have the skill set you
still have to have the handout
these are things that are developed
through causing neurons to fire together
and wire together
in such a way that you become super
proficient
at a particular action um am i right in
thinking that there's no
real advantage you say basketball i
believe that a
female just you know a biological
uh anatomical female could uh compete
the same way as a male could in certain
positions
on a basketball court or am i crazy for
thinking this way
well you know you're not likely to see a
biological female in the nba
um you know so so so there
is is certainly something to the male
female divide
but but if you're looking at transgender
women on
on average they're four or five inches
taller which
which is certainly an advantage that's
an advantage i would say that
uh that transgender women and this is
really hard to quantify this but i
i am certain that transgender women are
quickness disadvantaged
with respect to other women and and so
does does this balance out well you know
there are
no transgender women in the wnba so it's
hard to say for sure
but but i i don't think even in
basketball
that that trans women are so advantaged
as as to make uh competition
unreasonable
and and that's that's my point is that
you know there are so many other
variables involved that
you can't flatly say oh hey you have
this great advantage because you're
transgender you
you know that's all i think a lot of
this is political and a lot of it has to
do with social bias
more so than an actual uh empirical
representation of true advantage but
i i'm going on record as saying that is
an opinion
so so i can't you know that's my opinion
okay and and you know you're right there
are a lot of people
who who still think of transgender
people
being really the the sex they were
assigned at birth
or the gender they were assigned at
birth and so
a lot of people think trans women are
really men who are pretending to be
women
and that's where they have a problem and
so they think of
men invading women sports but trans
women
certainly in terms of gender identity i
mean
trans women are not faking who they are
nobody who would go
through all the things that transgender
people have to go through just
to succeed in sports yeah and you know
that's a wonderful thing you just said
there
is exactly nobody's going through all of
this to
uh truly uh acknowledge their real
identity
just so that i can win a medal
or a trophy
[Laughter]
i'm sorry but it's i i'm with you on
that one i'm just listening
to joanna there and you spoke in your
article in the washington post about
fear
the fear of other athletes and you said
oh we don't mind you competing as long
as you don't beat
us is that just born out of pure
ignorance
um you know i i
i don't want to to label people to
but um you know i i think
if if people have a chance to
compete uh closely with and against
transgender athletes
you know this sort of fear will go away
and you know
as a runner i have good years and bad
years and good years and
good races and bad races and people
who've raced against me a lot they
understand that that some days they'll
beat me and some days they won't and
and and so um you know we're we're
athletes like anyone else
so is there anything that can be done by
any of these organizations sanctioning
bodies or governing bodies
that um can make inclusion easier
and are they looking to make inclusion
easier or is this really just a
political football that must be handled
you know the the primary job of sports
governing bodies is to govern sports
and you know inclusion is is not their
primary
goal but okay but you know
yes they they do have a certain
responsibility
to you know to try to be inclusive
as long as they can maintain equitable
and meaningful competition
within whatever categories they have
determined are
appropriate for their sport and so are
there things they can do
yes and um you know the the
ncaa has certainly made an effort
um the international governing bodies
the iwf
and the ioc they're working on it they
you know they've got a ways to go but
um they have both an intersex athlete
and a transgender athlete
among 12 worldwide experts that help
advise them on this
and that's pretty good representation
right there and and we're working on
things
that's good that's good to know and and
you know you you have such a very
i will say measured and level-headed
approach to this whole thing you know
i'm i
quite admire the way you approached and
broached the subject matter
because for some reason this ins uh
incites a
very passionate and emotional response
from so many people
you know one that i don't get maybe it's
because i've never been a real athlete
you know what i mean
aside from playing some intramural
sports in school i
you know i i don't know what it's like
to have like you know to feel like
everything's on the line or whatever so
i'm not sure but it's
it just really incites not only from
players but also from the public
this incredibly like passionate fiery
response and you know i'm just a little
i'm a i'm not as good at understanding
that it's interesting joanna when we
talk about
where the answers might come from and
what things are beginning
to take place to find the the right path
forward
we have currently case to summania who
i believe and correct me if i'm wrong is
considered to be
hyper androgynous can you explain that
to me so as i don't
tread all over it and make the mistake
of thinking
[Music]
first of all but for me it is
yes it means someone um with
uh naturally high levels
of androgynous hormones and testosterone
is is the most common
androgen that we know of so um
the thing um and if you look at the new
ioc or the iwaf rules they actually have
gone away from calling them
hyperandrogenism rules they're now
called dsd
regulations and i think that's a better
term because there are
um there are things like polycystic
ovary syndrome that can cause
a hyperandrogenism in females not not as
high level as as having testes but
so so talking about the various dsds
that they do in the
new iwaf regulations i think is a step
forward but
hyperandrogenism is a natural level of
high testosterone and in the restricted
athletes that comes from having
internal testes there are some of these
dsds or
intersex conditions where a person can
be born
with external female genitalia but
internal testes and some but not all of
these people when they go
through uh puberty go through very much
a meal type puberty
where they get pretty much full meal
advantage now not on all of these
intersex people do but some do and and
this is is the
the problem for sports you know this
person has been born
was declared female at birth raised
female and then goes through male
puberty
what do you do with that person here's
what i want to know about that though
um when you talk about i'm not with the
dsd
why is it that that's never an issue
when it's male and male like there are
some men
who are just naturally superior physical
specimens and no one says anything about
it
with i i point with without any
compunction
to lebron james you look at lebron
james on the court and lebron james
is physically superior to everyone on
the court you can
visibly see it you can see it no one
says
well the only reason he's good is
because he's naturally he's got a
natural advantage
nobody says that because they know what
how what kind of work goes into getting
there
so why is it that we focus only on
females
with this i mean i don't i'm i'm trying
to figure that out you know and why is
it okay for men
to have a natural advantage but for
females
not to have a natural advantage okay so
we divide athletes into male and female
categories
and we do so because men are hugely
advantaged in
almost every sport so we want women to
win
things like olympic gold medals um
but there is no superman category if
there was lebron james would belong in
that superman category
but but we don't have one of those
categories we have a male category we
have a female category
and we have to find some way of dividing
human beings into male and female
athletes
so that's why there's no upper category
for lebron james
uh usain bolt etc etc but
um but we do have a female category and
a male category
and so we need to pick some way
to differentiate and and i would suggest
that using the appearance of external
genitalia at birth
is not the ideal way to do it but for
the purpose of sport but that's how we
divide human beings uh at birth you know
we
we divide them by that uh the appearance
of external genitalia but
in terms of sport it's not optimal so
let's speaking of that because we're
almost out of time and this is
fascinating and you're so great at
talking about it and educating people
so that being said what would be
a prescription i'm not asking you to
solve this problem right now but
is are there any ideas are there any um
efforts what would be the prescription
that you feel might help this
problem along what i would suggest is
that we use an evidence-based
method that relies on a biomarker
that is an important differentiator of
male versus
female athleticism and is mostly
dimorphic
um testosterone
fills all those boxes but we'd like to
come up with something better than
testosterone
we are starting to do some pretty
exciting studies
we are currently studying two
transgender athletes one in the
denver area one in the phoenix area as
they transition
and we are learning a lot and we very
much hope to have
these studies going around the world in
the next few years
and i think we can learn a lot and i
think we can come up with better
biomarkers in the future
so joanna as we sit here in sort of like
beginning mid
october 2018 next month the i
double a f will introduce new
testosterone ruling
which correct me if i'm wrong again
we'll see athletes with higher levels of
testosterone
being put into a medication program that
lowers
that and and they focused strangely
enough on the 400 meters the 800 meters
and the 1500 meters which
happens surprisingly enough to be cased
as a menia's
particular chosen field of track events
how has the world reacted to that
well many people have been reacted very
negatively
um you know
those events were chosen not because
they're caster symmenous events
but because those are uh a
events which a 2017 study
undertaken by a couple of scientists
showed
advantage uh for higher testosterone
levels
and b these are the events that over the
last 25
years have shown uh
that intersex women have a huge
advantage um
i have a paper that's just been accepted
for publication
and there's like 15 co-authors but one
of the things we looked at
was how do intersex women do in those
events over the last 25 years
and we found that they had a 1700
fold over representation in those
restricted events
at global track and field championships
over the last 25 years
so it's not just caster submitting thank
you
for for pointing that out is very good
is the iwf
action the best way
forward or is there a glaringly obvious
other paths that can be taken um
i'm not certain it's the right way
forward
i'm not certain it isn't um caster
sumenya is
is it appears is going to challenge
those rules in the court of arbitration
for sport
and we will see what we will see
absolutely we will
oh my god this is fascinating stuff but
we are out of out of time unfortunately
and
hopefully maybe um we can just revisit
this as a
um kind of like a a a epilogue so we can
after after the trial and all the
hearings and other
maybe we'll be able to get you back on
and just kind of revisit this if you
don't mind
no no i i would be happy to do so after
the trial
that's very generous of because this is
a this is a moving
thing this thing is going to move
forward and i think we need to keep
ourselves acutely aware of it so dr
joanna harper thank you so much
for your insight and your patience with
chuck and i and explaining some very
simple things to us thank you very much
indeed
you're not simple at all you're very
generous as i said thank you
all right chuck um every day's a school
day my friend
yes it is and i'm glad today i actually
paid attention in class
i think we all are and we look forward
to your company on the other side
thanks for participating in this episode
we pulled from the archives
from back in 2018. i'm neil degrasse
tyson
your personal astrophysicist and your
host of star talk
sports edition as always keep looking up
[Music]